Ever since the first Zombieland staggered
into theaters in 2009, fans have clamored
for a sequel.
We had to wait a full decade for a follow-up,
but from new zombies to every major storyline
in this long-awaited sequel, here's everything
you need to know about the ending of Zombieland:
Double Tap.
As the film opens, we find our four main heroes
making their way to a new yet entirely familiar
home: an abandoned White House.
They spend a little time being a dysfunctional
family, then hit the road again after Little
Rock runs off with a pacifist named Berkeley.
Along the way, they kill a bunch of zombies,
meet some new friends, get up to some Elvis
shenanigans, and have a short-lived run-in
with a couple doppelgangers.
“Oh, God, those are T-800s, or at the very
least T-700s.
There actually was no T-700.
Yeah, T-800's the first model.
It's great having two of you."
Things get back on track after Nevada, the
proprietor of the Hound Dog Hotel, tells the
group that she saw Little Rock and Berkeley
and knows where they're going.
This all leads up to the gang heading to Babylon,
a commune which promotes a pacifist way of
life.
It's mostly just filled with twenty-somethings
doing the world's last remaining drugs and
playing hacky sack, despite the hordes of
zombies that have taken over the planet.
"No worries, man.
No, there's some worries, man.
There's some worries."
As the gang sets off, they end up finding
a familiar and fairly unwelcome face on the
road: the very bubbly, very ditzy Madison,
who everybody thought got shot earlier in
the film.
As it turns out, Columbus didn't actually
shoot Madison.
She never even became a zombie at all — she
was just allergic to trail mix.
With Madison in tow, the gang finally finds
their way to Babylon, a seemingly successful
stronghold complete with an enormous tower
that's protected by walls on all sides.
Much to the gang's dismay, guns are confiscated
and melted down at Babylon.
After reuniting with Little Rock, the gang
realizes that she's happy being with friends
her own age, and they all realize they need
to give her a little room to live her life.
Tallahassee, who has been itching to return
to the road for the entire film, decides to
leave Babylon and set off on his own once
more.
But as he drives away, he notices a ton of
super-fast zombies heading right for Babylon,
which is, of course, setting off fireworks
and playing music as loudly as possible.
Tallahassee reverses course immediately and
returns to Babylon, warning its inhabitants
as he tries to figure out a course of action
to defend the complex considering there are
absolutely zero weapons on the premises.
Eventually, they come up with a solution involving
plenty of biofuel and fire.
It seems to work...until it doesn't.
The four heroes find themselves surrounded
by zombies, thinking the end has finally come.
In the end, Double Tap doesn't dispose of
its four main characters during their final
showdown; at the last second, a monster truck,
driven by Nevada, arrives to mow down as many
zombies as possible.
Once they all pile in, they return to Babylon,
where the weakened residents are attempting
to barricade themselves against hordes of
vicious, superfast undead.
Tallahassee's plan, as it turns out, left
no stone unturned, thanks in part to his newfound
heritage.
Early in the film, he bores Columbus with
an explanation about his Native American bloodline,
rattling off a long story about Native American
hunters luring buffalo off of a cliff.
Since nothing in the Zombieland films ever
happens by accident, it seems inevitable that
this story would end up serving an important
purpose.
Naturally, it does.
As Tallahassee lures the zombies upstairs,
it turns out they have a trap laid on top
of Babylon's highest tower.
For a moment it seems like Zombieland's toughest
hero might fall, but his littlest friend comes
to his aid.
Babylon might not allow any guns, but Little
Rock snuck one in; specifically, Elvis' gun
that Tallahassee gave to her for Christmas,
which she uses to shoot the last of the zombie
horde and save Tallahassee's life.
In the aftermath of the massive zombie attack
on Babylon, several characters come back together
for happy endings.
Tallahassee and Nevada reunite, and with Little
Rock's blessing, Madison and Berkeley pair
off.
Most importantly, Wichita turns to Columbus
and says the only word she needs to say — "yes"
— and the two officially get engaged, despite
Wichita's misgivings about marriage and the
pair's recent split.
Along with Nevada, the gang drives off in
Elvis Presley's pink Cadillac, with their
destination completely unknown.
When asked where they should go together,
Columbus simply says, "home," ultimately elaborating
that, with his chosen family, home can be
anywhere in the world.
It might seem odd for a zombie movie to have
such a happy ending, but that's simply the
Zombieland style: it lets its heroes have
everything they want, even as the world around
them crumbles.
"They were the closest to something I'd always
wanted, but never really had.
A family."
Of course, no Zombieland film would be complete
without a celebrity cameo, particularly after
the first film's Bill Murray guest spot.
Naturally, Murray comes up pretty quickly
in the film; shortly after the gang meets
Nevada, she says she almost "Murrayed" Tallahassee,
explaining that shooting a human you think
might be a zombie is called "Murraying," thanks
to the little case of mistaken identity that
happened in the first film.
"Is that how you say hello where you come
from?"
"Oh my God, oh my God I can't believe I shot
Bill Murray."
During the credits, Columbus gives the audience
a glimpse at Murray's first day in the zombie
apocalypse, which initially finds him conducting
unenthusiastic press interviews for the fictional
Garfield 3: Flabby Tabby.
After Al Roker succumbs to the zombie infection,
Murray mows his way through a press room,
gleefully taking out zombies while quoting
everything from Ghostbusters to Caddyshack
to, well, Garfield.
"I hate Mondays.
Just hate 'em."
The ending of Double Tap sees our heroes literally
riding off into the sunset.
But as with the first film, which ended in
a pretty similar way, the movie definitely
leaves the door open for a possible third
Zombieland.
However, after a ten-year wait between the
first Zombieland film and its sequel, it also
seems as if assembling the teams on either
side of the camera might be a pretty Herculean
task.
Emma Stone, Woody Harrelson, Abigail Breslin,
and Jesse Eisenberg are all more in demand
than ever, and writers Rhett Reese and Paul
Wernick have been involved in a ton of high-profile
projects since they made a splash with the
first Zombieland.
With that said, zombie stories are always
an extraordinarily rich creative well, so
a third Zombieland film would likely not only
be well-received, but well-attended to boot.
If Double Tap closes out this witty, clever
series, its ending serves as a perfect coda
to this extremely fun saga.
But if the demand is there for it, there are
definitely still more stories to experience
alongside Columbus, Tallahassee, Wichita,
Little Rock, and their new friend Nevada.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.